The differences in our genes come about
through a natural process called mutation.
Mutation is extremely common. As a
cell copies its DNA before dividing,
it makes occasional typos. Most commonly,
a single base is substituted for another.
Sometimes a base is deleted or an extra base
is added. The cell is able to repair most of
these typos. But each round of cell division
introduces a few changes that are not repaired.
When DNA changes occur in cells that will give
rise to eggs or sperm, they can be passed down
to offspring. Each one of us has about 60 new
variations that were not present in our parents.
People commonly use the terms mutant and mutation
to describe something undesirable or broken.
But mutation is not always bad. Most DNA
changes fall in the large areas of the
genome that sit between genes and they usually
have no affect. When variations occur in areas
of the genome that code for proteins, they often
have consequences. These changes can effect the
protein product itself or they can effect
when, where, or how much protein is made.
Most of the time, mutation generates variations
that are neither good nor bad, just different.
While a mutation is defined as any alteration
in the DNA sequence, biologists use the term
“single nucleotide polymorphism” (SNP) to
refer to a single base pair alteration that
is common in the population. Specifically, a
polymorphism is any genetic location at which at
least two different sequences are found, with each
sequence present in at least 1% of the population.
Note that the term “polymorphism” is generally
used to refer to a normal variation, or one that
does not directly cause disease. Moreover, the
cutoff of at least 1% prevalence for a variation
to be classified as a polymorphism is somewhat
arbitrary; if the frequency is lower than this,
the allele is typically regarded as a mutation.
SNPs are important as markers, or signposts,
for scientists to use when they look at
populations of organisms in an attempt to
find genetic changes that predispose individuals
to certain traits, including disease. On average,
SNPs are found every 1,000–2,000 nucleotides in
the human genome, and scientists participating
in the International HapMap Consortium
have mapped millions of these alterations.
The DNA in any cell can be altered through
environmental exposure to certain chemicals,
ultraviolet radiation, other genetic insults,
or even errors that occur during
the process of replication.
Sickle-cell anemia is a disease caused by a change
in a single nucleotide, and it represents just one
class of mutations called point mutations. The
alteration of a single nucleotide in the gene for
the beta chain of the hemoglobin protein, the
oxygen-carrying protein that makes blood red,
is all it takes to turn a normal hemoglobin
gene into a sickle-cell hemoglobin gene.
This single nucleotide change alters only one
amino acid in the protein chain, but the results
are devastating. Molecules of sickle-cell
hemoglobin stick to one another, forming
rigid rods. These rods cause a person's red blood
cells to take on a deformed, sickle-like shape,
thus giving the disease its name. The rigid,
misshapen blood cells do not carry oxygen well,
and they also tend to clog capillaries, causing
an affected person's blood supply to be cut off
to various tissues, including the brain and the
heart. Therefore, when an afflicted individual
exerts himself or herself even slightly, he or
she often experiences terrible pain, and he or
she might even undergo heart attack or stroke
- all because of a single nucleotide mutation.
Mutations can also alter the way a gene
is read through either the insertion or
the deletion of a single base. In these so-called
frameshift mutations, entire proteins are altered
as a result of the deletion or insertion. This
occurs because nucleotides are read by ribosomes
in groups of three, called codons. Thus, if
the number of bases removed or inserted from
a gene is not a multiple of three, the reading
frame for the rest of the protein is thrown off.
Changes in the DNA sequence can also
occur at the level of the chromosome,
in which large segments of
chromosomes are altered.
In this case, fragments of chromosomes can be
deleted, duplicated, inverted, translocated to
different chromosomes, or otherwise rearranged,
resulting in changes such as modification of
gene dosage, the complete absence of genes,
or the alteration of gene sequence. The type
of variation that occurs when entire areas of
chromosomes are duplicated or lost, called copy
number variation (CNV), has especially important
implications for human disease and evolution.